here to give the Oscar for the  outstanding original score obviously it  was not one of the silent picture Awards  in 1928 as a matter of fact it didn't  come along until 1934 first winner was  one night of love the nominees this year  are John Williams for Close Encounters  of the Third Kind George Delarue for  Julia Maury Shaw for Mohammed messenger  of God Marvin Hamlisch for The Spy Who  Loved Me John Williams for Star Wars and  the winner is Olivia  big moment goodness the winner is John  Williams sister  George Lucas and Gary Kurtz for the  opportunity of composing a score for  your marvellous film and two-line lumen  herb Spencer in the London Symphony  Orchestra for a splendid performance I  think a great recording by Eric  Tomlinson and for myself ladies and  gentlemen my warmest thanks for this  very treasured award in marvelous moment  thank you